so as we continue our series on the
Marvel Universe vs. the Punisher we pick
up now with issue number three and the
reveal of society's collapse from the
perspective of spider-man so with the
last video ended with Peter Parker
making his presence known by taking the
priest and the young boy hostage with
Frank Castle arriving his showdown with
spider-man is actually a bit of a bluff
what I mean here is that where Peter
threatens to kill the child
if castle makes any sudden movements
castle responds by saying that you would
have no qualms executing spider-man on
the spot and sacrificing the child in
the process now the reason why I say
this is a bluff is that because the
Punisher had lost his wife and child
which set him on the course of becoming
a vigilante in the first place on the
whole he harbors somewhat of a sensitive
side for women and children while this
doesn't mean that he's unwilling to kill
women who attempt to harm themselves or
others it does mean that he allows them
a little more slack for children on the
other hand Castle avidly avoids allowing
them to be harmed by either his direct
or indirect actions due to their
innocence and the fact that he believes
that children are taught to become
criminals furthermore while spider-man
does call his bluff he also recognizes
the castle as curious as to why
spider-man would risk dying by showing
up at the home of castle knowing the
Punisher kills cannibals on site and so
establishing his good intentions by
letting the child live and releasing him
Peter initially provides a short one of
the events at transpired and relating to
the collapse of society by telling us
that when most of the superhero
community emerged as infected beings a
civil war had occurred between the
groups who split off into different
factions forming their own tribes and
claiming such as of Manhattan as their
own
however this shorter story is expanded
on when Peter tells us that prior to the
Civil War and after the infected his
split into tribes a massive battle
occurred between the infected and not
infected both human and hero alike
making a last stand at Coney Island
where he was like Tony Stark were able
to organize a national guard and use his
technology to provide a tactical
advantage their efforts were hindered by
the overpowering strength of infected
superhumans like Red Hulk Sabretooth and
beast however while this seemed to be a
series of uncoordinated attacks
spider-man tells us that an unknown
individual behind the scenes had been
manipulating the conflict driving the
infected and uninfected to battle one
another in an effort to thin out the
population and establish control over
Manhattan
in addition to this during the battle
where Captain America Wolverine and Iron
Man had done their best to hold off the
cannibals and end their rampage when the
utilities began failing and power
started dropping off because stalks
ability to operate his suit was tied
directly into Jarvis's technology when
the power went out the connection was
severed
leaving stark unable to exit his suit
turning the Iron Man armor into a
literal coffin trapping Tony Stark alive
where he screamed for five days until he
died and so when the conflict concluded
most of the tribes who had previously
taken up residence in Manhattan after
the outbreak had either been killed in
the war or simply moved on to other
parts of the world leaving the unknown
mastermind largely in control of
Manhattan furthermore and the months
following the end of the battle at Coney
Island
those cannibalistic individuals who
would remain outliers and refused to
join any one tribe were either forced to
join the king of death tribe or
systematically wiped out along with a
handful of remaining tribes attending to
maintain claim to Manhattan and so the
actions of Peter coming to the Punisher
for aid are revealed when he informs
Cassel that while the king of death had
been killing members of spider-man's
tribe during their hunting trips
somewhere along the line the king of
Death had also kidnapped spider-man's
mate now where Punisher is a little
skeptical about Peters request and that
it could be a trap designed to kill
Punisher and rid Peter of castles
constant attempts to kill his cook the
offer spider-man makes is that if
Punisher is willing to fulfill his
request Peter will provide the location
of where massive number of humans are in
hiding as well as maintain a ceasefire
allowing castle and the humans to live
in the territories around Manhattan
without fear being attacked meaning that
the Punishers goal of defeating the
cannibals who ultimately come to
fruition even if by indirect means now
what's interesting about this is that
maybe retire us a bit on the possibility
of whether or not Punisher would
actually engage in helping spider-man
achieve his goal one of the reasons why
I like this is that it walks a line
between the way that we view the
Punisher and how he views his role in
the Marvel Universe what I mean here is
that historically Castle was always a
more extreme version of Batman in that
light Bruce Castle had lost his loved
ones due to the actions of criminals and
had launched a crusade to ensure that
others didn't suffer the same
experiences as him on the other hand
Punisher is also a little more selfish
and then he doesn't grant criminals the
opportunity for redemption and instead
acts as judge jury and executioner
immediately determining their guilt and
killing them on the spot
however the request was spider-man
versus a scenario where castle would
essentially have to give up all of that
for the sake of protecting others
something that he's never really done
before and so after a heartfelt speech
by the priests Castle takes to the
streets of New York in an effort to take
out the king of death and return
spider-man's mate during his travels
however he's also met with the return of
Deadpool as well as the arrival of Black
Widow and scorpion
now something I want to point out here
is that much like the appearance of the
Incredible Hulk in our last video the
appearance of scorpion and Black Widow
in this video isn't really meant to add
a whole lot to the situation where they
do operate as backup for castle their
inclusion is also designed to beef up
the comic a bit and establish that
spider-man's tribe is largely composed
of both different members of his rogues
gallery as well as heroes who are
modeled after arachnids something else
to take notice here is that when Castle
Black Widow scorpion and Deadpool arrive
at the king of death camp were informed
that the base of operations has been set
up at the former battle site between the
infected and uninfected heroes now mater
doesn't really tell us why this was done
and even Punisher himself simply hazards
a guess but for the sake of rolling with
the story I would argue but using this
particular location is designed to be a
way for the king of Death to celebrate
his victory over both Manhattan proper
as well as the surrounding areas while
Punisher reveals a spider-man's kidnap
made is this reality's version of Mary
Jane Watson he also begins his campaign
of invading the base of operations by
sniping the various cannibals who
operate as part of the king of death
tribe or some of these cannibals include
toad as well as strong guy who has super
strength after the initial attack they
realized the entire scenario is an
ambush when Sandman she-hulk and a
multitude of other super-powered heroes
and villains emerge engaging in a
massive battle which involved Banshee
hammerhead in a host of other members of
the king of death tribe after realizing
that the odds are stacked against them
castle comes to the conclusion that
while there are a thousand ways to lose
a battle the only way to truly win is
scorched earth now for those individuals
who were unfamiliar with this figure of
speech a scorched earth policy is a
military strategy designed to destroy
anything of value or use while advancing
through or withdrawing from the enemy
territory while the United States has
uses policy on several occasions
including the Civil War when the north
salted the ground in the south and
pulled up railroad tracks within the
story The Punisher throws grenades into
the fighting cloud
killing Ally and enemy
like after which he attempts to rescue
Mary Jane now where Mayor berry also
tells us that Mary Jane is immune from
the infection but is also pregnant with
spider-man's child when Cassel is
distracted by this revelation he
suddenly knocked over the head by the
king of death who is revealed to be none
other than Wilson Fisk the kingpin with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and in the next
video we'll pick up with a conclusion of
this story and how the events unfold
regarding the humans the cannibals and
Frank Castle but that being said I will
catch you guys later peace